it's horrifying yet unsurprising and
that's sad because you want to preserve
your ability to be surprised though my
name is Sam aloe I worked in special
education for four years and now I also
am a substitute teacher for anything
from preschool to twelfth grade
hi my name is Salani and I am a science
teacher
I'm CT and I was a teacher's assistant
for two years teaching both fourth and
fifth grade and I'm Dan I was an adjunct
professor for one year at art school art
school and today we're gonna answer some
true/false questions the pupil to
teacher ratio in 1970 was twenty two
point three in 2011 to 2012 that ratio
was actually lower in public elementary
schools 21.2 a lot of numbers I mean
that just seems that seems like a hard
possible I feel like ratio is bigger
today the ratio is way bigger today
all right well yeah for the future
growth on average teachers who use their
own money on classroom supplies spent
four hundred and seventy nine dollars
although some teachers reported to spend
more than $1,000 on supplies yeah I mean
that has to be true I would say even
like higher than $1,000 I would say true
oh great I mean not yes it's not touch
this that sucks
terrible systemic problem only 6.8
percent of public school educators who
left teaching voluntarily in 2012-2013
cited salary and other job benefits as
the most important factor in their
decision according to a Department of
Education the survey false it's gotta be
more it would be insane if it wasn't
more it's a false actually what in the
2014 to 2015 school year 54% of public
school teachers said they spent their
own money on supplies for their
classrooms yeah sure that's so true
I feel like it's higher but I mean I
guess there are the ones that admitted
to it and then the ones that actually
did it right that is an adding number
known for here with your little tricky
lonely one word it got me as of the fall
of 2016 there were 1.6 million
elementary and secondary school teachers
working full-time in the u.s. why not
there's a lot of people in the world
it's too big
[Music]
Wow I know this we were correct about 1
in 50 teachers leave their jobs within
their first three years I regret it so
true absolutely false and it has to be
way hotter
[Music]
oh not one in 50 but one in five
although it's one of the most rewarding
jobs you can have because kids are
amazing it's not paid very well and it's
not the kiss it's the administrators and
right according to the National Center
for Education Statistics 57% of public
school teachers hold a master's degree
or higher oh I am only saying false
because I feel like you guys like to
trick like it's actually fifty five
years not fifty seven ninety two percent
yeah true true okay you're like I quit
it's it's true yeah that is definitely
true
Sylvester Stallone briefly taught
physical education at a boarding school
in Switzerland didn't he do softcore
pornography
sounds pretty random that's awful so
it's probably true I'm gonna say false
just because I'm gonna say false just
for
[Music]
it's true it adjusted for inflation
teacher salaries were 1% less for the
2015-2016 school year than they were in
1990 1991 1% less I think that's false
it falls to as false
I'd say adjustment for inflation yeah
yeah
I'm getting stressed yeah yeah it's
getting hot in here
corporal punishment such as paddling is
still allowed at public schools in four
states probably true because it just
seems like maybe there's some obscure
laws that haven't been taken off the
books
think that's that's true and I think
Texas is one of them I would actually
say that it's false because I would
imagine there's more where it hasn't
been taken off the books that it's legal
I mean is too many are you serious
19 states are paddling children I grew
up in the Florida public school system I
never saw a teacher directly strike a
student but I did see a lot of like
grabbing by the collar to remove them
from a classroom which is very
physically violent all right 63 percent
of teachers in the u.s. work second jobs
to help pay their bills oh yes hi I want
to say false because I bet that is
higher this is the number 63
[Music]
sixteen work second jobs oh well that's
great
who is taking these tests and who is
filling this paperwork out what because
I've never filled that paperwork out
yeah neither have all my teacher friends
yeah I mean I know like as an adjunct I
could not live off the salary I was like
a teacher that's why I worked two jobs
this game was very money I I feel that
there are still so many problems with
our education system in the United
States there there were a few that I was
surprised by I feel less positive about
our direction than I did when I sat down
because I thought we probably never
would have otherwise learned this okay
so this game just did us a real service
thank you to the teachers who are 94% of
us paying with our own money to teach
our students and and just being there
[Music]